the scene as a whole was it nice
i know what you mean
[Music]
welcome to s g we can't remember what
episode
um so mission
1k oh yeah mission 1k so guys
we get obviously messages
and comments and [ __ ] all the time about
the length
of the podcast and the frequency of the
podcast and stuff like that
so we're gonna make you guys a [ __ ]
deal do something for us we'll do
something for you
um so of course patreon
um we've decided once we hit
one thousand uh thousand pounds a month
on patreon we're gonna up this [ __ ] to
two times a week
reason for having to do to get to 1k
1k means we can drop our hours at work
once we drop our other work we have more
time to meet up we have more time to get
together we have more time to shoot
so um thanks guys help us to help you
man help us to help you
um links in the description um
and yeah extra there's extra episodes on
there as well so
you're not doing it for nothing so extra
episodes enjoy the bonus episodes on our
patreon
um please guys jump on enjoy let us know
what you think
and yeah man [ __ ] with it once we get
one thousand two episodes a week
two episodes a week probably guess for
two episodes a week perhaps i know i
know
they will be gusted too yeah yeah yeah
because yeah that'll be sick so
let's see how we go here we go um and we
go from there so guys as usual
like subscribe oh comment
bash the video if you don't like it or
whatever um
also sorry let's go also subscribe to
the
sng clips we've got um eclipse page
where
if you're not into watching the whole
podcast which you should be
um and you just want like snippets and
stuff we have eclipse page where we've
got different segments of different
topics
so it's about five to about 10 minutes
worth of good [ __ ] man and they come
from the episodes as well so you're not
really
missing out on much if that makes sense
yes sir so yeah mom
so yeah man it's [ __ ] boy monday
let's get into it talk to me and you i
was just saying any urgent business or
no
um not really pause
[Music]
monster sorry come in a bit come in a
little bit just a little bit i [ __ ]
asked you brother you are in it but your
whole body isn't in it
i don't care ah
sorry team all right gang go yeah
um you know when you get a massage not
like from a ting or anything like a
proper massage in like a masseuse joint
yeah yeah yeah
and obviously they have to they tell you
to strip down to your boxes or whatever
yeah yeah i was gonna say yeah yeah yeah
you look confused
sorry sorry go go yeah yeah and then
they put the towel thing over your body
and then they fold the ting in your
boxes and shift it down a bit
so there's a bit of crack yeah yeah
it's scary it infuriates me that they
have to do that do they have to do this
i don't know i think they do it because
they want to see how uncomfortable we
can get
bro it drives me insane you know what
the thing is
so when they do that [ __ ] this is the
thoughts that go through my head
so yeah obviously they get it down and
then they fold it under the boxes
and they're shaming it down a little bit
i'm thinking why is my ass
out why is it out and then i'm thinking
the fear in me makes me want to clench
my cheeks but i'm too but if she can't
come to me
she'll laugh she'll laugh
so i'm just having to firm it yeah
because i'm firming it whilst relaxing
yeah
i'm scared you're a humane instinct you
just think you're saying right yeah
you're gonna get penetrated yeah yeah
like my ass is relaxed and i'm i'm
laying flat on my stomach and it's out
and it's out i don't know what's gonna
happen
i [ __ ] oh it's frustrating anyone
who's a masseuse let us know is that
necessity
is it necessity because i don't need my
ass touched it doesn't need massaging
um so yeah man that yeah that doesn't
need to buy a random thought
that is a very random thought um
i've got uh like a i watched um
what'd you call it the other day white
lines okay
no no i've just heard a few things i've
heard good things about average thing so
i've not really been sold it's [ __ ]
average oh thank god you said it's
[ __ ] average
anyone who said it was good they haven't
seen things
they've not watched tv they haven't
watched things um
like it's so basic the main character
is jarring she's jarring i've seen her
inside announced before after because
i've seen i've definitely seen her
outside now i can't know what i saw him
but she's [ __ ] annoying bruh
so um she's a [ __ ]
and basically the concept is her brother
died
okay no no so 20 years ago brother went
missing okay
he went i lived to live in ibiza with
his boys he went missing
no one knows what happened to him and
then after like
a monsoon or some [ __ ] loads of rain in
ibiza
it uncovered his bodies they found his
body buried oh wow
in like some random place in ibiza so
she goes out there to identify his body
as his sister um and she's like all
right cool so he was murdered
so the police said yeah he's murdered so
she's like all right cool well i'm not
going [ __ ] anywhere until i find out
who murdered him so that's the whole
premise of the show
okay uh trying to find out who murdered
her brother kind of thing right yeah
yeah
the reason i'll bring it up fam [ __ ]
show
there is a scene there's some weird
chemistry between this one donnie
and his mum like a witness his mum his
own mom
okay his own mom there's a guy basically
this is like a second
um second or third lead of the show okay
and there's like a rich family
and they basically own ibiza okay
essentially in the show
and um the the like kind of
heir to the family business and stuff
him and his mom
they've got like a weird air about [ __ ]
they're very like um
how do i say they're very like uh
they're just close
but they're conspiratory and stuff like
that and they just like they're weird
like that
there's a taking a piss in the corner in
the car park over there
middle of the day no qualms um
that's [ __ ] distracting um so yeah
anyway there's one time so the whole
family's at war with each other yeah
about this and that this and that so one
time he's like all right cool
i wanna us to go to like family
counselling or whatever okay so they go
to do some family counseling
and fam spoiler alert it comes out that
he legit wants to [ __ ] his mom
legit wants to [ __ ] his mom it's the
creepiest thing
like so they're there and the sisters
like
the him and the sister have beef and
then they're going back and forth back
and forth back and forth and then she
dropped something like at least i don't
want to [ __ ] my own mom
and everyone's like oh shut up shut up
you [ __ ] shut up and then the
counselor is like
is that true and donnie's like
i don't want to talk about that kind of
thing let's move on and then the man's
like
fam this is open it's open no lies here
if you want to heal
we need to move forward before we need
to speak the truth
man says all right it's cool she turns
me on
to be fair mum's a milf yeah still i'm
not
i'm just saying for context yeah his
mom's [ __ ] banging okay
like for for a 50 60 year old woman or
whatever she's in there she's buff
buff she's sexy i'm after pre-dat just
for that for her you would breed it for
her she's sexy as well ah
she's slack i'm gonna have to repeat the
whole thing just for that yeah bro she's
buff
um but she's like a 60 year old buff
gee i'm saying that's fine bro yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's what i'm saying i
wanna i wanna [ __ ] a milf
yeah before i die i wanna [ __ ] milk
exactly so she's like she's like
old milf but like you can't go in there
just thinking she's any buff woman
like you have to see her for what she is
okay an older woman
and then once you've addressed that
you're like she's actually very [ __ ]
okay okay okay
anyway they're out of counseling like
fine it's true yeah um i want to [ __ ] i
i like
mom turns me on his home his own dad is
there and the mom and dad are still
together his own dad is there what the
[ __ ]
fam is creepy and then they asked um
the ask the [ __ ]
the mum like did you know about this and
she's like
i'm not gonna lie yeah i did i knew like
did he used to run into my room when he
was scared when he was 12 years old
yeah he did did he used to get in bed
with me yeah bro he did
did i feel a boner on my [ __ ] ass
yeah
sometimes i did okay then she says
and what did she say and did i
soon learn that i didn't have to wiggle
my ass for very long before i felt a wet
patch
yeah bro yeah i did
fam she used to shake her [ __ ] ass on
my man's tool
i'm assuming why these men are fake
spooning in bed because he's scared
yeah and she'd feel rock hard at all on
her body
she'd rub her arse against it and the
man would nut in his pants
and she said the excuse was she any
mother just wants to know that their son
is healthy and their [ __ ] works
fam that's west most convoluted family
that's west nah bro i was thinking raw
either she's mum of the year or she's a
demon woman
she don't make sense she's crazy she's
crazy i don't know how to process that
bro
the whole show was [ __ ] but that scene
had me
captured i don't know how to process
that
do you know what i mean yes yes i do
what
it's a weird it's a weird concept why
why is it in the white lines what's it
what's it do
with the like coconut this is about
cocaine well actually
it's about cocaine kind of it's very
loosely about cocaine that's whole
reason i watch the show because i
thought the whole thing is about cocaine
okay i was just about
like cocaine drama and i was like i
could get i could [ __ ] with you yeah
yeah um but it's not really it's about
like
she uses it as like some weird analogy
like a weird metaphor
like oh i'm living between the white
lines of such and such i don't know
one of them yeah one of those sayings
isn't it
but um yeah just just what i put out
there man just it's a it's a weird
waiting it's a [ __ ] show but if anyone's
watching on netflix and disagrees
i'm not i've not watched it i'm
definitely not going to watch it now but
if anyone disagrees or has any
tapence let us know man because that's
very interesting especially that topic
about the moment
speaking of milfs yes it's not it's not
going anywhere you think it's going yeah
i'm not [ __ ] off i don't want to [ __ ]
them up but do you
think i think i was talking to bella
about this
a few days ago or last week do you think
that
okay when nearly 30 unfortunately
unfortunately yeah
and i still want to [ __ ] him off but
but okay do you know you know what i'm
going you know where i'm going with it
you know where i'm going with it
i think i think you know where i'm going
with it yeah i feel i feel like if i
[ __ ] milf now
it doesn't feel the same because i'm i'm
old now
but do you think this is the thing as
well though because when you were 18
and you [ __ ] a 30 year old you would
have think you would have been thinking
i banged a milf
but now if you [ __ ] the 30 year old
you're just banging someone your own age
yeah now
now the the barriers have moved now
you're talking 40 50
yeah i know because i was thinking
if i banged the thing that's 45 i
wouldn't really say she's a milf because
i'm i'm basically 30.
now 45 is a milf fam 45
i'm not [ __ ] a 45 year old woman out
of bang the milk yeah but
yeah at the age of 18. no well like 20
or 30 family
to be fair when it's to do with me i
don't know about age and stuff like that
because i just know how i feel
yeah i just know in my head i would feel
like i banged her mouth if i banged a 45
year old woman
if i met a woman and she told me she's
45 years old and [ __ ] in my head off
bang the milf okay
i'm not thinking well i'm 30 uh i don't
feel 30
yeah fair i don't think that and in my
head yeah a 45 year old woman is
older than me 45 cars
45 maybe i don't hang around with enough
45 45 seems old to me
it does don't get me wrong it does seem
old but
it's not like 50 60. 56 if i bang a
thing is 60 or shaky that's not even
milk anymore
shaky shaky
yeah for me to [ __ ] a 60 year old
what am i even doing to be in that
business
where are you in the first place to even
be in the same room as her ah
that's weird that's weird i don't know
i don't that's mature that's the pornhub
category
mature speak it up
[Music]
have you ever been on pornhub yes and
obviously you're scrolling through the
melting melting
and then you might see like do you ever
go down a rabbit hole in
in pornhub and you think how the [ __ ]
did i get here yes i
bro there's been times where
there's been times that obviously remind
me to tell your story about that all
right
not a story about ramen there's like
obviously times where
you're going through this and that and
then maybe it would be like
oh like a lisa and vid might pop up
yeah yeah and you were like lisa and and
yeah you're thinking oh lisa and i
haven't looked at her
yes yes so then you search lisa anne and
then lisa and starts coming up and then
just like lisa and milf thing and you're
thinking [ __ ] at least that is a milf
and then it's like milf something
something and then you go through your
milk smell smells
and then one buff milf sun yeah and then
it's like mature
milk and they're like she's bath
and you searching mature me often and
then you click it's grannies
it's just grannies and you're like
how did i get it this is not what i was
looking for
this is not what i was looking for oh my
god that's funny and then you bash
anyway
we're here now my dick's in my hand
there's no
i'm not going back i'm pulling that this
has been like seven minutes
this is more of a task yeah yeah it's
not worth it
what i was gonna say was when you
whenever you do bash to the great thing
anyway because we've ended up there
anyway
obviously you go clean up whatever you
close all the times or whatever yeah and
remember
when we spoke about a few episodes we
spoke about bashing multiple times a day
oh god yeah when you when you go for the
second or the phone round or whatever
and you want to try and recreate what
you watched before
you think how the [ __ ] do i get back to
what i wear because when you find a good
batch oh my god i open bear tabs when i
find a good batch i open bear tabs
but then obviously when i'm dying i
don't keep the tabs open
yeah incognito is wiped gone but what i
want to go for round two
i'm trying to find those specific videos
and it drives
fun insane trying to find specific porn
videos is the most jarring thing
there is a video especially when i can't
remember their name especially when i
never remember their name never
bro there's a specific video that i
watched when i was a teenager cause i
think i know no
say say because i for some reason i
already think i know the video
and i don't know why i'm telling you you
can't i think because you asked you sent
me a
you asked me a question about oh [ __ ]
just say ah just say say
there was a video i don't remember i
don't know how it got there or what
yeah it was definitely a pornhub yeah
and it was a secretary yeah
yeah getting banged by one guy yeah one
black donning
yeah there's nothing else there's
nothing too specific about it
but the the scene as a whole was it nice
i know what you mean and then and then i
just never thought about it again
yeah because i was young i was trolling
yeah and these times i'm like
i need to find that video again yeah and
i've never i've searched for it fam
i've searched not even like to the point
i'm so to the point where i'm not even
in a wanking context anymore yeah you're
just trying to find it i'm just you can
reference i'm just on my laptop
so glasses on just like need to find it
so i can favorite it
i will never be able to find when you're
ready to walk again so i'm ready to
specially again
bro i can't find it i spent hours
looking for it it's just gone in the
ether
done i'll never find it again i'm so
vexed about it that's not what the one i
thought you got because
for some reason you were telling me
about i think you told me you watched
one one time
and she was she was just wriggling on
man's piece
do you remember and i was thinking
that sounds like a giant michaels video
because as soon as you said
a man disclaimer a man said he doesn't
remember names by the way
i remember there's a few he reeled off
that name bro there's a jet jenny
michaels i remember her
lisa and i remember her um there's
another one called
alicia something that i can't remember
she's buff
um i don't know there's sarah j oh she's
retro fatties
yeah yeah yeah i remember really ones
that i don't care about it's weird
because it's the ones you started with
yeah yeah they're all true
you're right you're right that's how i
know their name um but these days i
don't know any names
that sounds like a giant michael's thing
because it's her that's her i remember
that scene
because i've seen that i've seen that
one for soul because this is so old
yeah yeah yeah i remember that scene so
vividly and i don't know why
bro jokes have you ever watched the
bonnie rotten
i know yeah the chick would have spied
away
i was thinking i tried to reel she's
she's a
that's when you're in a dark place if
you find yourself on a bonnie rotten and
then just have to bash it out anyway you
feel so
the post not shame is disgusting why
because she's so raw she's
so raw i prefer raw though no but yeah i
do
but fam like she's really really like
she's
vile like like it is you you're finished
and you're just like you know when i
said the other
day when you like you want sloppy top
yeah and then afterwards you just wanted
to be drenched
like drenched and they're just like and
you're like yeah yeah that's what she is
i saw a meme sorry to cut you off sora
meme that said
she sucked me off so good how to wipe my
arse when i was done
that sounds like a sloppy that's a
sloppy
song for that stay away from us but i'm
game for the same time because she was
sucking it so much it dropped like it
trickled
to the gooch area that's sloppy top
i read that i was dying that's made me
sweat i was dying when i read that
oh [ __ ] that's made me [ __ ] sweat
brav oh jesus sorry what were you saying
anyway jonah michael something something
i'm sorry [ __ ] i can't even remember
because i don't even remember that way
in itself was a rabbit hole
oh it was that was right that was funny
bro we got um
this is what i'm going to try and do
more of because we always get fan
requests
on either comments or messages or
anything
i don't want to zoom it zoom it out i
can't is that the first that's a zoomy
zoomed
okay let's find you i don't mind if i'm
not all in it it don't matter all right
um yeah it was um
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] get back together
fan requests we always get them are like
oh you guys should talk about this
and i'm always like yeah yeah yeah we
will and then i [ __ ] forget about it
i always do so i like i'm gonna try my
best we did one last time with the
the not last time but a few episodes ago
with like the period
one period sheets
you remember talk about it all right
never mind no
but you said you said
when we talk about you banging on period
oh snap yeah yeah i remember now yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
you say period cheese
sheets period cheese spam
that's what i heard so i was perplexed
okay say no more um
so previous relationships
i thought we could get a good good on
this one so you have to be open and
honest with this one
you go first so one donny so basically
this is what this is what i put down in
my phone because i actually wanted to
make it like i want to know
what i was on about when i had them that
you know when you have something in your
head yeah and you have to add
more notes than you need to yeah so just
to remind you where you were in the
headspace when you had this thought
i did that all the time it drives me
insane yes annoying bro it's not organic
yeah
i hate it but anyway so um
cool so i thought basically donny just
messaged us the other day and said he
likes when we talk about our previous
relationships i think i saw that
um so i thought we'd do
something fun
you pick a relationship from my partner
talk to me like i'm a stranger
pick a relationship from your past tell
you what
or someone you were seeing yeah tell me
why
you got together yeah what it was saying
as a whole
yeah the relationship yeah and why you
broke up
okay and you have to be open honest i'll
do it first if you want me to
yes i'm trying to i'm trying to see
which one i'll pick
cool you know what i mean and i don't
want to start one and be like that's not
good enough then
i mean so you go personal cool i'll pick
one
um
cool so i want to see if you can
actually guess who it is as well i
probably will you will get to be fair
and once i get into it you'll get
straight away yeah
so this one was a go this is an
interesting one because this is like a
it's like a weird kind of
time in my life where you get with
someone that you don't
you don't necessarily know why you're
getting this person do you know what i
mean
like you just i don't want to say in
ruler i don't want to say like a time
filler
or anything like that it's just like
you don't necessarily see it going
anywhere mm-hmm
but you know what you mean you think
it's cool at the time yeah but even
with your emotions yeah yeah yeah you're
running with it at the time but at the
same time
if someone asks you like oh do you see
yourself marrying this person stuff like
i don't like to think like that anyway
but at the time you're just like
probably not but it happened to happen
yeah yeah yeah with emotions so i got
with this person
um when i got with them anyway just
because i thought they were cool
i just thought they were funny yeah and
cool um
and i was just kind of seeing them and
then it just got into something a piece
more
yeah um and then
the the the dynamic of the relationship
was weird
weird in that like
do you ever you ever be with someone and
it's okay sorry guys bella's just i
causing a ruckus
um you ever get with someone and then
like
even in the midst of relationship you're
just like
what even is this what if it's like
just like i said at the time it's like
cool
we got together i didn't care about
where it was going anything like that
yeah
i was just invested in what i was doing
at the time but now we're here
it's like but actually what are we doing
yeah because i've got a life to live
and it's just like it was just like a
red ship of pure routine
like she will come to my house and watch
movies
[ __ ] whatever and then we'll get on with
our day and all this stuff
and then like and then like l words just
started getting
thrown around here and there and it's
just like this is not actually even how
i
feel because it's like what is it it's
just like a weird relationship that you
find yourself in
and then you get deeper deeper and once
you're there for too long you're like i
never gonna
get out you ever did that he's like i've
been here this long now i don't think i
can even get out
i know that feeling i do know that
feeling and then we used to argue so
this is the same person
this is the same person i've said on
here before when they said like we would
argue
and then when they said when i told them
to come out my house
and they said what are you gonna do beat
me up like my mom said you would had a
feeling was that yeah of course
what a comment what a comment from then
i wish that's one of the points where i
was like we're in deep enough
i felt like we're in too deep for me to
just bounce
into d for me to just bounce when i that
day i should have just been like
yeah big man why am i putting out with
it yeah yeah get like if you didn't
actually get out my house you don't have
that you don't have mentality back then
i didn't you don't i didn't i don't know
what changed around me to make me a bit
more cutthroat but i think
this was literally the beginning of that
the cutthroat james well
just like my life is more important than
any of this [ __ ] yeah because the
the re because the reason i asked you
explain why you broke up was because
this person it wasn't even a thing like
that
i literally went into work one day i
remember i
just i've been at my job at david lloyd
for like a week
and i was sitting in the office with my
manager alone and um
i looked at her and i was just like
randomly out of nowhere i was just like
what do you do in i just explained my
situation i was like what are you doing
in that situation and she's cut throat
as [ __ ] she was just like lucky
lock it and i was like all right man
cool
text her and i think i was just like big
man you happy
and then she was like well i think we
might have argued that they have
something petty i was like baby are you
happy
and then she's like well yeah i'm happy
well this this why are you not happy and
i was like
nah just straight nope i think this is a
wrap
out of nowhere and the thing is as well
it felt
good because i thought she's gonna think
i'm a [ __ ] for this
but trust me i'm doing her an injustice
if i was to just carry on with this
[ __ ] [ __ ] cause
like that would be such an injustice to
this person um
and boy i've been
happy ever since
but yeah man it was just like also i
think
this is stupid besides slight sidestep
breaking up with people over text has
such a bad rap
but it's essential cause bro that's my
story
that's my story breaking up someone
overtakes a such a bad rap
but why would you do it any other way
why would i want to do it face to face
exactly why would i want to go through
that no i'm not the easiest option
i don't want to be i'm telling you i
don't want to be with you so why would i
go to be with you to tell you what i
want to be with you
out of respect i'm trying to lock you
out my life
respect goes out the window now respect
for what we had now i'm done here
move oh but yeah tell your story so
funny enough the first time i saw you'll
probably remember who this is i don't
know if you remember her name
but you might remember her alias
um i saw this chick
on my friend's snapchat it was
the day we came to manny this was way
before i lived in manny we came to mani
i think it was a night out i don't know
why we're up here but it was just a
night out and it was probably about
2000 and when i moved 17 so it's
probably about 16. okay 2016 or whatever
no 2015 it was it was def it was
definitely 2015. okay
definitely um we were out and then i saw
it was the day we were coming back
like going back to our yard or whatever
from manny yeah and then i saw
a chick on my other friend's snapchat
and all i saw was body yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i think i know who it is yeah all i saw
was body and a message is like who
the [ __ ] is that she's like oh this is
my friend right
there i was like say no more hook the
thing up unless let's see what gone
gang and she was like oh messenger
yourself or whatever like she i think
she gave i ever gave me her snap or she
gave me her number i don't remember
um so we started talking slightly
talking started talking she lives in the
other ends
of london we met up i can't remember
when the first time we met up whatever
but we started dating we liked each
other we started dating it was cool
whatever whatever
day in day and day and there was no
issues but it was one of them ones where
i felt like like you said it's not
really going in my head it wasn't really
going anywhere i think i was doing it
because
at the time it seemed fun but now the
fun is kind of
over we're just in a relationship per se
bro that's exactly the same it's like it
seemed fun at the time yeah but when the
fun dies down because the thing is as
we're talking about sorry to interrupt
your story
but like the thing i was thinking about
when i was i wasn't being able to
explain it properly in my in my story
but like
it seemed you you you started because it
seems fun
at the time yeah and then when the fun
stops
because the difference between that and
a normal relationship is that normal
relationship isn't isn't fun anyway
you don't get into it because it's fun
yeah yeah you just get into it because
you like or love that person yeah
and then when you get with someone
because they seem fun when the fun dies
down you're just like
it's literally like the betting adverts
if the when the fun stops stop
bro you have to stop but um yeah so your
date and date and date
it could have been about three to four
months maybe i can't remember how long
it was
um but there was a period of time
i was interacting with my
previous ex as well yeah do you remember
who it is now
yeah so interact with my previous ex as
well and then we were
talking starting to get to to that level
again
and but i had told my ex that i was
seeing someone
so i was being open and i was being open
and honest i wasn't being energy or not
being truthful gang but it didn't make a
difference
because
the way the way the way it all patted
out the way it all patted out i had to
lock off because i wanted
at that period of time the way it was
going i wanted my ex back
so i had to lock it off with the girl i
was seeing
without a valid reason because i wasn't
going to obviously say to her
big man i'm leaving you because i want
to go back tomorrow yeah yeah yeah
no one does that no no one does that so
i can't remember the excuse i gave but
it was over
a messenger on whatsapp again like i
said it was the it was the immature
immaturity thing like i didn't have that
mental space to have the conversation or
have the do you know what i mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it wasn't wise enough then yeah so i did
it over whatsapp and
it was it just was it was [ __ ] it was
[ __ ] from me because obviously it's not
something i wanted to do
and it was [ __ ] it was [ __ ] for her
because she didn't see it coming
i was just about to ask you do you think
she had any inclination that this
inclination i'll tell you another story
as well yeah yeah no inclination
whatsoever so that's what made me
feel even worse because like
it was a win-win for me whereas for her
it was just a loss
do you know what i mean so i'm leaving
her to go back to one yeah
she's just getting dumped oh she didn't
really know why you know what i mean
i had to do it over text and it was like
but karma
karma caught up with me so that happened
time ago and there was another situation
where i was seeing a girl
um you know who is um you know for a
couple months or a few months
um we're going out date everything was
fine everything was fine
no issues didn't hardly really argued
and then
there was a period of time i started to
gauge like
she was she wasn't moving weird but she
was talking weird via whatsapp and stuff
you know when you could just sense
there's something wrong you don't know
what you're making sense to something
like yeah
i think i messaged you saying i bet this
[ __ ] is gonna break up with me
i don't know if you remember but i do
not remember this but i think i messaged
you saying
i guarantee you this [ __ ] is going to
break up with me and this was probably
about two days before
so she messaged me saying uh can we meet
up
at so and so so we can speak or whatever
and i think i screenshot that to you and
i was like oh this [ __ ] is definitely
gonna break up with me
yeah i'll tell you who he is after
remind me yeah yeah so i went to meet
her or whatever
but prior to that she was talking the
most about how oh we're so good together
to tear we should go on holiday we
should do this we should do that and i
was fine with that yeah yeah yeah
yeah it seemed because the fun was still
fun yeah it seemed like the right thing
to do
you know what i mean i was fine with it
so when she messaged me that oh
can you meet me at x y and z whatever
whatever
i was blindsided bro blindsided long
story short she broke up with me
and i was like where is this coming from
do you know what i mean
where is this coming from because a
month ago there was no issues we wanted
to go on holiday and [ __ ] like that
but then a month down the line you're
like and the reason is because obviously
she
she moved c and i was like you know i
know who it is no no
it makes sense yeah go on she moved city
and i was like
at the time because
so i felt like the chick in the previous
story where
you didn't realize it was coming so for
me it was just a loss yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know what i mean so i was like
a month ago you were saying we should do
all of this and now you're saying this i
was like what the actual [ __ ] that's why
i said karma
karma came real fast so i got mine as
well um but it's
it's crazy because you never know what
end of the stick you're gonna be you
always think you're gonna be control
relationships are hard whoever brought
up this whoever said this by the way is
it's a good conversation
very good conversation yes um you never
know how things are gonna go man so
that's the thing man like in
relationships these days it sounds
harsh and everyone i've ever told it to
things i'm a [ __ ] for saying it
but i can't
like when i'm like i can't even like
like if i get my words out
like even to the point like we could be
like if we're living together
or if we're married or anything i'll
happily openly say like
i love you today yeah but tomorrow
isn't guaranteed because just like i
just been through it now yeah i've been
through the the peaks and troughs
and then like you said like sometimes
[ __ ] is fun at the start yeah
and then it just gets boring and then
you just lock it and sometimes
it's fine and then you start arguing out
of nowhere and then sometimes again it's
fine and then she might just
just bang yeah i've also never been
dumped
i've been dumped i've once i've been
dumped more than once guy i remember the
one at the store i just saw i remember
that vividly
but i feel like i've been dumped before
again but i don't remember i've never
been dumped
but because of that my guard is
up up up not my guard but like i'm
always waiting
yeah for my karma like you said kamikaze
i've always been waiting like every time
i'm happy
i'm always like this is it this is this
is the one
this is the one that's gonna [ __ ] me
over all come crashing down she's gonna
[ __ ] me over
um because i've been a [ __ ] in my life
i've been a [ __ ] in my life
i've been a [ __ ] in my life so i just i
just know one day i'm gonna get [ __ ]
over
but like it's it's one of them ones man
it was jokes
to go through the motions because i'm
thinking about all these people brother
and i'm just like [ __ ]
is there any speaking of speaking of
speaking or speaking i'm thinking about
the psy again sorry is it is there
anyone is there any times that you've
been with someone
that you think if you could go back i
would never have got with that person
not necessarily because they were a bad
person
maybe because it was a waste of time in
terms of data in terms of sex
date not not sex not sex just dating
just dating people
because i'm pretty sure like my first
three girlfriends oh i know that for
sure for you yeah for sure
rags rags actually more for them because
the one before that the one before that
story
no include sorry including that story
everyone
up to her or everyone up to her plus one
more
no everyone up to her including her oh
yeah it makes sense
yeah yeah rags so yeah that means i
would have been single
all my life up until like 20 [ __ ]
i don't know i don't know either early
20 twenty early
four i was gonna say twenty-five yeah um
but yeah man i'll wipe it all clean
and that's bad when you think about it
because i had good times with these
people
let's fly in here because oh bro
good good times with these people i've
only had
one i would say i'd only have three to
four proper girlfriends
and i can't say i'd want to wipe
anything away
i feel like i've experienced a lot from
each one
and there's no bad blood there's nothing
for me to be like oh [ __ ] you i wish i
never did yeah yeah
i feel like i've grown from every single
female i've been with yeah in terms of
relationships i think there's definitely
times where i've been in relationships
though
where like the reason i said i should
have never probably got with them
was i think sometimes when it was when i
say it was fun
yeah actually just kept it as fun yeah
and never moved it any
further than that yeah or there was
times where
being with that person i genuinely
wasn't happy
but i didn't it sounds dumb i didn't
even know i was supposed to be [ __ ]
happy
do you know what i mean like you knew in
relationship when you're in relation to
someone
yeah especially when you're young you
think like
when they do [ __ ] that pisses you off
you feel like
this is how it's supposed to be okay
this is i'm like supposed we've
obviously spoken about it before but
like you feel like this is how it's
supposed to be i'm not always supposed
to be happy
and if like i remember specifically when
we were at uni there was times where i
i remember i said it to you lot all the
time where i had
the girlfriend the main girlfriend at
uni and i said like
i feel like um i have all the negative
aspects of being in a relationship with
none of the positive because she lived
away so i didn't really see her that
much
but i still got all the grief and i
still got none of the [ __ ]
i couldn't [ __ ] anyone else i was barely
[ __ ] her because she didn't live
there
yeah and i'm getting all the grief all
the texts all the [ __ ] catching up
and all this stuff
having to like brav do you remember when
the girls used to beef you about how
long you stay on the phone for
when you used to have to stay like all
when you when you first get to know
someone you used to stay on the phone
for hours because
yes i've been on a phone four
times bro when you'll be on the phone
for two
hours longer longer that's that two
hours
i can't do more than two hours i was on
the phone before three to five
oh four yes five nah yes are you talking
to anyone for five hours when we're chin
wagging which we're talking fam when
we're getting to know each other
that's juicy that's to be fair that's
juicy oh
fam fam and then now when it starts to
simmer down to like 30 minutes you're
like
why are you saying yeah why do you never
always bending like oh do you want to
talk before bed and i'm like
not really i know everything now yeah i
know i know
you i know you now i i just [ __ ] all to
find out about you i can guarantee you i
can tell you how your day went well
all we're gonna talk about was how uh
how was your day fine how was your day
fine
now we've got six hours to make up for i
don't even know what we're gonna talk
about
and just like yeah just having like
pressure to stay on the phone with
someone and [ __ ] like that
just petty little [ __ ] like that i think
that's a such a young mentality though
because obviously that happened
at a younger stage of our lifetime
because that that could never happen now
no one could ever pressure me to talk to
it's not even i don't know
it's not even about the pressure thing i
just don't think it happens now like it
doesn't happen to the older generation
because we're mentally past that now do
you know what i mean i've got a job fam
you know what i'm saying i've got [ __ ]
i've got bills to pay
i've got bills to pay them bring all
that [ __ ] around me
i've got so much on my head i don't want
to hear the outcome is large
you'll never get what you want in that
conversation i've got bills to pay
the tax man is hunting me down on a
daily basis
[ __ ] off oh [ __ ] yeah yeah bro it's
that's
crazy all right cool so in that case
in that case oh [ __ ] real quick because
i forgot to look for one anyway
am i the [ __ ] yeah for breaking up
with someone over text
this is this is how it's going to be
it's biased because i've done it before
yeah that's why who the [ __ ] hasn't done
it before
true like who what kind of gentleman
or woman takes the time to meet
up with every single person they're
about to break up with to break
like i don't think i've ever met up with
the person but but
both stories i've been on both sides
i've broken up via text and i've been
called up
to come to meet them and been dumped
would you prefer okay in that situation
would you have preferred if she just
text you it
or are you grateful that you met up with
her and i feel like
i feel like i am grateful because
if it was over text i wouldn't have had
it there was
especially because i i was blindsided i
didn't see it happening
i wouldn't have had it there is no way
in hell you're locking me off via
whatsapp
i wouldn't have had it so that's why i'm
in the blue yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that means that's why i'm a hypocrite
that's why i
said i've been on both sides yeah oh
you're that see that makes me feel like
the girl that you did too
was [ __ ] pissed off oh she was she
was because i remember she
i saw her i saw her about three years
later in manny
oh that blindsided me to rot i didn't
know she was here i didn't know why she
was here
i just saw a group of girls come in and
i saw her i was like what the [ __ ]
is going on and then she added me on
snapchat which was very random like the
day afterwards inside and i just
we don't speak but it was it was so
bizarre it was so bizarre but yes you
are the [ __ ] because i've
i've been the [ __ ] and i feel like
purely because i blindsided her she had
no inclination it was coming
it's to be on that receiving end because
i've been on that receiving
end it's it's not nice bro it's not nice
and the reason why i said i prefer it
face to face was because
once we spoke face to face obviously our
messenger afterwards in red
and i i dropped a bar saying if i knew
this was the last time
if i knew the last time was the last
time
i would have put in that work oh
everyone's busting everyone's bicep
actually came around the next day
[ __ ] sometimes like xx
we [ __ ] james
that's gang also don't break up i mean
come around my hot yard the next day and
it will still broke no don't do that
don't fun fun fun
so obviously i was on the high from the
sex yeah she stayed over
and she dipped the next day and never
saw her again never
saw her again i don't think i knew that
i never saw her
but like we messaged and stuff and blah
blah blah i've not seen her since that
day
i've not seen her since that day that
was time ago
this is what i hate women because women
won't actually do that though
women will actually break your heart
[ __ ] you again
and then just leave just leave and then
when you're like what's going on you're
like i told you yesterday i told you two
days ago we're not together what did you
expect
but the funny thing is she did the
the the right thing she definitely did
the right thing because
my calling calling you to oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] you're what oh locking the whole
thing off
oh the whole thing lock and holding
what's that
because thinking about thinking about it
when i'm out of it
there's no way i would have kept it up
no you were different people fam
you two not weren't you didn't fit
this thing it's the funniest thing i've
ever seen you man didn't fit
human didn't fit i know it was sexual
attraction and that's it
it was attraction and that's it that's
i'm getting so hot but yeah
left never spoke to again i never saw
her again rather we still spoke right at
her
but i think
yeah i was gonna say she did she
definitely did the right thing because i
would never have kept it up
and for her to think about to for her to
be in the headspace of
thinking about the future whilst we're
together and whilst we're good
she's a big she's a bigger person that
makes sense does that make sense that
makes sense
so i understand why people do what they
do especially when they do it face to
face
i understand it because they've foreseen
waguan the same way i did it
with the other thing but obviously i did
it via text and the reason why i did it
via texas was because i like i said
beginning the story she lives on the
other end
i'm not driving all the way there or me
linking up
neutral ground to then drive all the way
like yeah
it's long regardless of why i owe you
it's log the thing i did it to live five
minutes from me but i still wasn't doing
it yeah i know
i still wasn't doing it i was just i
don't know it was just like i know i
think it's a stupid question i know i'm
the [ __ ] yeah but it's like
i also don't care because i'm i'm
actively trying to get rid of you
i know what you mean and the more of a
dick i can appear then it's probably the
better
the better because it's easier for her
to like it's easy for her to just deal
with it like you know when in films
where you're just like a pet that won't
[ __ ] off
and you're just like man i don't even
like you just [ __ ] off yeah and then
they turn around and they're crying
like that's how i felt obviously i
wasn't crying but i was just like i'm
actively trying to get
get away from you so like the more
the whole in my head i'm like if i meet
up with you and we sit down and we have
a drink or whatever and i'll try and
break it down
and obviously i'm a pussy-old that's the
main concept yeah i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i can't stop crying we're together again
yeah
if you start crying yeah yeah we're
together again yeah
yeah i'm too scared i can't deal with it
yep oh
yeah so if in order for me to get out
what i need to get out
i just have to text you guys i need to
text you just [ __ ] oh do you catch it
yeah yeah oh my god yeah it's actually
your hand is it my i can't look but i
know it's in here
mr miyagi thingy guys if you're
listening i just caught up you just
caught a fly
in mid-air i need to get up so let's
wrap it up anyway yeah
because yeah yeah we're both [ __ ]
but yeah
thank you guys we'll see you next week
jesus you qualify